Rick Wiles is a christian-based
conspiracy theorist and a racist and an
all-around horrible person for the
things that he has said and done over
the last several decades we've talked
about him before but not in a while and
he now has a program on something called
true news pru News which he created he
used to work for the Christian
Broadcasting Network he eventually went
over Trinity Broadcasting Network these
are all extremist far-right Christian
media organizations and as you can
probably guess just from what I've told
you so far
Rick Wiles is anti-gay Rick Wales's
anti-immigrant Rick wiles is
anti-semitic he's checking off all of
the normal boxes that we would expect
him to check but he's now going after
faux meat burgers I guess veggie burgers
black bean burgers mushroom burgers
lab-grown meat impossible burgers that's
a new vegan burger that is around which
I've tried before I guess all of these
are part of the problem that is designed
to steal people's souls by preventing
them from being able to be born again
take a look at how he said it don't take
my word for it when you go to your
favorite fast-food restaurant you're
going to be eating a fake hamburger
you're going to go to the grocery store
and buy a pound of fake hamburger or a
fake steak and you won't know that it
was grown in some big corporations
laboratory this is the nightmare world
that they're taking us into they're
changing God's creation why they want to
change human DNA so that you can't be
born again that's where they're going
with this to change the DNA of humans so
it will be impossible for a human to be
born again they want to create a race of
soulless creatures on this planet I know
I've said this before but if fake
burgers are so terrible and if his god
is so powerful why didn't his God just
prevent the creation of vegan burgers
right like if this is such an evil that
needs to be rooted out
why would his all-powerful and
all-knowing God allow the creation of
vegan burgers and this entire critique
about vegan burgers destroying people's
souls in all of it this is the wrong
critique of vegan burgers the right
critique of some of these burgers is
that they're mostly not very good I've
had some pretty good non meat burgers
like at some restaurants that make them
in-house but every prepackaged veggie
burger I've tried has been mediocre even
that impossible burger that people are
up in arms about saying it's so great
recently tried it it looks like and has
the consistency of raw meat even after
you've grilled it it's just not that
good that's the tragedy not that it's
going to destroy your soul as it was a
massive plot to prevent you from
becoming born-again and by the way if
you're distraught if you want to destroy
people's souls to prevent them from
becoming born-again Christians through
getting them to eat veggie burgers
you're failing because most people I
know don't like veggie burgers the
veggie burgers are going to have to get
way better if you want more than a tiny
fraction of the population to start
regularly eating them in order to self
destroy their own Souls
but seriously does this guy believe what
he's saying or is it all stick maybe to
sell stuff or I don't even know if he
sells stuff maybe just to make money and
get donations I went to the true news
website it's completely whacked out with
conspiracy theories but you can donate
they will accept shares of stock you can
donate cryptocurrency you can leave
money to them in your will can you
imagine they will also accept precious
metals from you it's it's really a scene
that they're going there and then by the
way and this is where it all comes full
circle where you can take action you can
submit prayer requests no matter how big
or small the requests they say you can
submit prayer requests on their website
please go to true news.com slash prayer
that's TR u news.com slash prayer submit
prayer requests that are related to the
David Pakman show they can be inside
jokes
anything goes if any of these get aired
or answered by Rick wiles we will
absolutely play them on the show if we
hear about it which you might have to
tell us since I certainly don't watch
this garbage
but true news.com slash prayer let's see
if we can get some a progressive or
david pakman show inside jokes mentioned
there